I'll be honest when I was looking
through the list of Disney animated
films and I came across saludos amigos I
never even heard of it
I thought I knew most of the Disney
hand-drawn films but this one totally
slipped my mind and to be fair there's
kind of good reason it's not very long I
don't even think it's really a
full-length motion picture I think it's
about 40 minutes and on top of that it's
just sort of a weird premise a bunch of
the Disney animators decide to fly to
places like Brazil and Titicaca and so
forth to give them inspiration for their
cartoons and that's it it's literally
just the animators going around doing
drawings and showing you the cartoon
that came up with does it really count
as a movie I don't know I can see that
much more as a feature read or a
making-of or a behind-the-scenes bit but
as a movie it's not very interesting
maybe if we got to know the animators a
little more shot a little better but as
is it just sort of looks like someone's
vacation videos with just cartoons the
only cool thing about is that you do get
a little bit of culture that's always
nice they show you what different words
mean they show you different parts of
their land so at least you are getting a
little bit of an education out of it but
even the animation is just their normal
cartoon animation I loved the cartoon
animation but to see an entire movie
like that like naive an entire movie 40
minutes heck even the 40 minutes isn't
entirely animated it seems like kind of
a letdown I don't know I'm not sure how
to judge it seeing how it's not even
motion picture length but I often see it
on the list of animated Disney films so
I guess I'll include it here and
actually this is the birthplace of that
one Green Parrot I think most people
think he came from three copy arrows but
nope this is actually where he was born
because that's kind of the only bit I
remember really enjoying was when they
were singing the song Brazil and you see
this paintbrush go through and actually
paint Brazil this is awesome Disney
doing what awesome Disney does taking
shapes and colors and playing with it
you think you're looking at a tree but
maybe you're looking at a bird you think
it's a bunch of bananas but with a
splash of black you're looking at two
cans stuff like that is great and the
rest of the film was like that maybe I'd
enjoy it more but
is it's pretty forgettable it might be
good to put on just as a time waster for
your kids like I said it does have a
little bit of culture in it but as a
movie it's not that groundbreaking if
you just want to say you've seen them
all go check it out but aside from that
I'd say it's probably a decent